Muslim refugees are dangerous I know
because I've never met one tens of
thousands of Syrian refugees are
definitely in many cases Isis aligned so
I've come to the belly of the beast I
know it looks like I'm in Mosel or Raqqa
but I'm actually in a town equally as
dangerous Twin Falls Idaho cyclic
Breitbart and Drudge and Infowars have
told me that there's an insurgent
refugee presence here out for blood and
I'm gonna go find
Siri find Isis in 2016 a shocking story
came to light championed by bright
Bart's lead investigative reporter Lee
Stranahan headlines from across
conservative websites claim the three
Syrian refugees with ties to terrorism
had gang-raped a five year old at
knifepoint in rural Idaho so I'm in Twin
Falls to file a story about the terror
marauding refugees the discussions of
terror of marauding refugees and Twin
Falls is so blown out of proportion I
can't even hardly describe it why should
I believe you a person who lives here
all the time
over myself who has read things on the
Internet
but mister Stranahan was connecting dots
that really had no business being
connected but I'm confused
Breitbart indicated that this case
involved a knife and their lead
investigative reporter lisa rinna hands
article said gangrened Sharia law
Syrians even Isis seems irrefutable to
me
prosecutor address the rumors going
around on social media the incident was
not a gang rape the assailants were not
Syrian and the assault did not happen at
knifepoint
that's all absurd if they were Syrians I
would tell you they're Syrians and but
it bothers me
just because his office prosecuted the
case doesn't mean he knows anything
about the case and who cares what the
New York Times The Washington Post in
several Idaho news outlets debunked I'd
seen this on sites I trusted there had
to be Syrians lurking in Twin Falls
somewhere we have not resettled any
Syrian in in Twin Falls as of now it's
zero Syrian I was reading an article by
Lee Stranahan and Breitbart and he
doesn't agree with you sir he did not
meet with the experts on refugees it
seems like he had an agenda the refugee
is a victim of terrorism you're not
really helping me tell the story I need
to tell so I just want you to repeat
after me
refugees are not criminals refugees are
not criminal great now can you just
tighten that up
throw out the knot I can't get anyone to
give me the answers I want why the court
sealed it to protect the victim and the
suspects in this case because of their
age it was investigated the young men
were prosecuted and sentenced so there
was an assault according to the New York
Times a seven-year-old boy was accused
of attempting some kind of sex act with
a five year old girl and a ten year old
boy allegedly used a cell phone borrowed
from his older brother to record it but
apparently the case was sealed because
it involved juveniles so prosecutors and
police are barred from discussing
certain details in sealed juvenile cases
but Stranahan and his boss Steve Bannon
knew it was less likely that officials
were respecting the privacy of children
and more likely that this was a global
conspiracy I was going out now to Twin
Falls Idaho to least Ranahan the
situation since it's happened has been
hushed out the mayor of Idaho a big you
know sharia supporter that's what we're
out here on the ground getting dude wow
Stranahan was shrewd enough to see that
this was a classic small-town sharia
supporting mayor coverup and he
heroically confronted the City Council
about the case
[Music]
leave investigative journalists with
Breitbart news you're a city official
sir
you made statements were just read that
were not true sir it turned into this
conspiracy theory to prove a point that
refugees were inherently dangerous that
Muslims were inherently dangerous maybe
a conspiracy of truth I think that there
are legitimate concerns that people in
Twin Falls have there's a wave of
Islamic terrorism we're seeing it every
few days now and this helped drive the
totally reasonable national conversation
about whether Muslim immigrants belong
in America at all from Twin Falls
there's hundreds of them in the town
they're gonna is Lama fathers area we
have to be careful who we let in this
country you've seen what's going on in
Europe and it's not just about
terrorists this is about the rape
statistics that are going on there look
mr. Stranahan just rightfully afraid of
refugees so don't the ends justify the
means here not at all my wife and I both
received death threats recently a woman
Member of Parliament
she met with opposition perform of a
bullet to the head
she's dead now they buried her nice day
have a nice day what a polite death read
the article even inspired Russian trolls
to get involved organizing
anti-immigration rallies and Twin Falls
to stir up trouble and all of this
coverage was happening during the 2016
election and fueled voters fears that
Muslim immigrants really were as
dangerous as Trump said this is
absolutely the best reporting I've seen
in my life all journalists took a local
crime and used it to mobilize a national
conversation about a completely
unrelated issue people call it fake news
but these citizen journalists were able
to cause real-world chaos how could I
learn to make high-impact journalism
like this then I found my solution hi
there my name is Lee Stranahan there's a
reason I've gotten story after story
after story right when everybody else
got it wrong I believe in bravery that's
why I started citizen journals in school
click right now and we'll see you on the
inside that's right the X
journalist behind the twin false story
runs his own citizen journalism school
while most of his school is online he
was having a weekend intensive in
Washington DC so I paid $200 and signed
up and Here I am to learn from the man
himself Lee Stranahan unfortunately
Stranahan wasn't as happy to see me as I
was to see him soon after I left citizen
journalism school he posted this Colby
sorry dude you're busted you got to
understand I'm not afraid of you he's
not afraid of me and I'm only slightly
afraid of him find out if I become more
afraid tomorrow
on the opposition
[Music]